dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with carriage on a4a here let's
talk about the mathematical intricacies
of the elections here you can see the
shape of the 12th congressional district
in north carolina in the nineties this
is not a naturally shaped electoral
district is it
one might say this is more of an
abomination if you try to understand why
it has this peculiar shape we shall find
a remarkable mathematical mischeif have
a look at this example of 50 electoral
placings the distribution is sixty
percent blue and forty percent read so
this means that the blue party should
win the elections and gain seeds with
the ratio of 6240 right well this is not
exactly how it works
there's a majority decision
district-by-district regardless of the
Volt ratios if the electoral districts
are shaped like this then the blue party
wins 520
however if they are shaped like this the
wrap party wins 3-2 2 which is kind of
mind-blowing because the votes are the
very same and this is known as the
wasted vote effect this term doesn't
refer to someone who enters the voting
booth intoxicated
this means that one can think of pretty
much every vote beyond 50-percent +1 to
a party in a district to be irrelevant
it doesn't matter if the district is one
by 99% of the votes or just fifty
percent plus 1 volt so the cunning plan
is now laid out what if instead we could
regroup all of these extra votes to win
in a different district where we were
losing and now we have ceremoniously
arrived to the definition of
gerrymandering which is the process of
manipulating electoral district
boundaries to turn the tide of an
election the term originates from one of
the elections in the USA in the eighteen
hundreds were governor average Jerry
signed a bill to reshape the district of
massachusetts in order to favor his
party and at that time
understandably all the papers and comic
artists were up in arms about this bill
so how does one perform gerrymandering
gerrymandering is actually a method
medical problem of the purest form where
we are trying to maximize the number of
seeds that we can win by manipulating
the district boundaries appropriately it
is important to note that the entire
process relies on a relatively faithful
prediction of the Volt distributions per
region which in many countries is not
really changing all that much in time
this is a problem that we can solve via
standard optimization techniques now
hold on to your papers and get this for
instance we can use metropolis sampling
to solve this problem which is
absolutely stunning
so far in an earlier episode we have
used metropolis sampling to develop a
super-efficient light simulation program
to create beautiful images of virtual
scenes and the very same technique can
also be used to steal an election in
fact metropolis sampling was developed
and used during the manhattan project
where the first atomic bomb was created
in Los Alamos i think it is completely
understandable that the power of
mathematics and research still give many
of us sleepless nights sometimes
delightful sometimes perilous it is also
important to note that in order to
retain the fairness of elections in a
district based system it is of utmost
importance that these district
boundaries are drawn by independent
organizations and that the process is s
transparent as possible i decided not to
cite a concrete paper in this episode if
you would like to read up on this topic
i recommend searching for keywords like
redistricting and gerrymandering on
google scholar please feel free to post
more interesting findings of yours in
the comments section will always have
excellent discussions there in thanks
for watching and for your generous
support and I'll see you next time